quand elle s'élance comme ça tel un
aigle à plus de 4000 mètres d'altitude
christine malet nice éprouve des
sentiments indescriptible avec ses
autres licenciés la championne du monde
de vol relatif prend plaisir à partager
ses sensations fortes
c'est d'avoir un petit peu le monde à
ses pieds quoi c'est vraiment une
bouffée d'air frais et puis bon vol
donc voilà c'est génial de la simple
débutante à la grande compétitrice de
haut niveau les sportifs de toute la
france ont décidé de conquérir les airs
de l'indre pour toutes ce rassemblement
féminin de la fédération est l'occasion
de se bonifier et de s'entraider aussi
lorsqu'on saute avec des personnes d'un
niveau différent on est obligé de se
mettre un petit peu à leur place de
penser à leurs problèmes de se rappeler
les problèmes qu'on a pu avoir quand on
a dit débuté dans une discipline et
c'est beaucoup plus agréable
organisé pour la première fois dans la
région cette cinquième édition a pour
but d'encourager les femmes quel que
soit leur situation à s'impliquer
davantage dans la discipline depuis 1789
la femme de garnerin sautaient d'une
montgolfière
donc c'est dire aux femmes nous sommes
et nous pouvons faire encore plus on
fait la pratique du sport parachutisme
mais on peut s'investir dans un travail
dans un boulot on peut construire sa
carrière professionnelle on peut prendre
des responsabilités au sein des
associations
la fédération compte 53 mille licenciés
dont 28 % sont des femmes
et